foreign
is from Caroline
I'm Caroline and I'm a new patreon
subscriber in the UK I've just had a
baby and we'll need to look for a job in
a few months time after losing one of
mine while on maternity leave my
background is journalism but more
recently I've been working in PR and I
remain a local politician which is low
paid but highly stressful takes a lot of
time and won't sustain my family
financially in the long term losing a
job has affected my confidence despite
knowing it was not due to my ability and
that I'm extremely capable I have lots
of transferable skills but I'm finding
the decision about what job to look for
overwhelming as there are so many jobs
available at the moment across many
different sectors previously I've had
lower paid but stressful jobs in the
public or charity sectors as I wanted to
help others and for my work to be
meaningful but because of the stress and
the bleeding of work into my personal
time in previous roles and still in
politics and also now having a baby too
I'm tempted to apply for roles that need
less input or critical thought at the
expense of purpose and my ambition
there's also the question of how many
hours to do versus child care costs
which are massive in the UK at the
moment and whether to go for a
short-term or permanent role there's
just too much choice on top of me not
being sure what I want to do next what's
your view on this and what does
minimalist job hunting look like
so Wendy a few things stood out to me
when I was listening to her question a
few things from your book so you talk
about either or thinking in the book and
so I just want to talk about this you
where you say this is on page 67 either
or thinking is limiting at best
detrimental at worst and I think
sometimes we think as though well in
order to be a successful parent I can't
have a job in order to have a job I
can't be a successful it's that either
or thinking where it's incredibly
limiting and it can even be detrimental
so that both Things become a catastrophe
in our lives of sorts and then later in
the book you also talk about assumptions
I know we already talked about earlier
the the discomfort and how in a way
except because she's uncomfortable right
now but accepting that discomfort is
rather comforting in in a way or it at
least increases your ability to
experience Comfort or experience less
discomfort but can we talk a bit about
the either or thinking and can we also
talk about assumptions with respect to
Caroline's question yes Caroline again I
love the question and my answer to that
question of do I go for the lower paying
but passionate job or the higher paying
but stressful job the answer is both
right if someone gives you a choice
between A and B do you know what the
right answer is
C the right answer is C and uh just
noticing that the framing of this is
that false dichotomy it's that either or
it's that question of A or B so we can
start with how do we shift the question
change the question because that opens
up all kinds of possibilities this goes
back to the study part of the studies
that we've done where our colleagues in
our colleague Ella Maron Spector and
insead invited people to just change the
question between an and and an or in an
experiment and it opened up all kinds of
new creative possibilities so if we
start it by saying how can I what is
possible for both a job that I'm
passionate about that I care about that
I'm excited about and that will allow me
the kind of resources that I need for my
new child for my family for what I need
to have a productive and happy life how
can I do both that's the start I love it
I mean I I keep going back to uh values
like that when I when I was listening to
her question it's like
I know for me um when I got my first
high-paying stressful job it was all
about the money and that's you know
that's what I
obviously valued because that's what I
was going for in every promotion after
that it was just more money but it was
also more stress and it wasn't until
um I got to a boiling point where I'm
like okay something has to change and uh
what changed was me getting clear on
what I wanted out of uh not just my job
but my life and I mean you can go to the
minimalists.com forward slash uh V yeah
yeah and you there's a values worksheet
there and it's super helpful because
like this is the foundation this is like
the compass I think anyone should use
when they're making these major life
decisions and I agree like it doesn't
have to be either or there's something
out there it's going to take a lot of
work but that's that's what simple is
simple is not easy simple is a lot a lot
of work it's a lot of dedication but
um yeah I think that she totally has an
opportunity here to get everything She
Wants it's uh it'll take a little time
though for sure
I I love so simple is complex there is
complexity and simplicity and
um you know I love the values worksheet
we talk about connecting to a higher
purpose so that's your why that's your
values that's your what's the purpose
and it's partially to align your
decisions with those values and it's
partially that the higher purpose and I
know you talk about the values of where
do you want to see yourself in 10 years
what's your future self how do you align
with your future self so connecting to a
higher purpose is thinking out to the
Horizon the long term if you look if
you're dealing with conflict and you
look out to the Horizon it studies that
chaos in the moment it studies the the
choppy waves so the values create that
long term they also create this
overarching framework where the inner
conflict these competing demands can
both coexist so if you have a conflict
between two people one of the ways to
start in navigating that conflict is
what are we trying to accomplish
collectively so uh again I'll go back to
my husband and I might have conflict
over what are the ways we want to
discipline our kids around screen time
screen time's a big deal in our family
how do we but the the over he might have
a point of view I have a point of view
we're conflicting over which way to go
the overarching higher purpose is we
both love our kids and want the best for
them okay in the context of that we can
then negotiate how to move forward so
for Carolyn in the context of what's
your higher purpose what's your
long-term goals you can navigate how do
I accommodate that in the moment
achieving my long-term goals a steady
happy family productive self productive
kids in that context I need both
resources to enable my kids to be happy
and I want a career that I'm passionate
about and it's in that context that
those two can come together yeah yeah to
answer the the last question she asked
about what is minimalist job hunting
look like I will say this ultimately the
the North Star is I can't believe I get
to do this and we talked about this last
week or a few weeks ago on the private
podcast but we I when I come in here on
Tuesdays we do these we do a live stream
on Tuesdays and
oh man I can't believe I get to do I
have to leave my house at like 5 30 a.m
to get here on time and drive down from
Ventura County but I get to do that and
ultimately get to is so much more power
than powerful than have to now it's true
that sometimes you'll have to do some
things to get to the area in which you
get to do them right but I would do this
for no money whatsoever I'm grateful
that we have a list of patreon
subscribers who pay us and they pay
Jordan and Sean and Emma and Jess and
Mallory and Danny and everyone else on
the team and they help out but I would I
get to do this and so like it's
wonderful to get paid for the thing that
you feel like wow I get to do this and
so if you don't feel like oh yeah I if
you or let me rephrase that if you feel
like oh man I guess I have to do this
okay that's uh maybe a stepping stone
but that's not where you want to end up
you want to end up somewhere where it's
like oh I can't believe I get to do this
I think that's right to to add to the so
I think the process is start with your
value start with your higher purpose
know where you're going your North Star
I think the next step is knowing what
these competing demands are each about
what do you want the resources for is it
in service of just pursuing money well
that unto itself can be kind of empty
but those resources are valuable you
need them what are you passionate about
really separate it we talk about it as
separating and connecting separating out
your different pieces because that will
allow you to come back together and find
something better that your passion may
be local politics but there might be a
whole lot of other things you're
passionate about along the way it gives
you lots of possibility then I want to
add one more thing because I think it's
really important in this both and
thinking which is
we tend to think that both and thinking
is about finding the ideal win-win in
the moment and sometimes that happens
that's great your win-win your ideal
hybrid your integration we call it the
mule because it's the hybrid between the
donkey and the horse but both and
thinking and both and thinking is also
about noticing that we're making lots of
decisions over time we might not find
that ideal win-win in the moment we
might be shifting between these opposing
ideas in in micro succession
experimenting along the way until we
find that moment that we finally hit
that perfect ideal yeah it's beautiful
our next question is from Sarah
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcasts available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free
[Music]